this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason today we're going to talk about
some important New Revelations in the
ongoing mystery around the origins of
covid-19 although maybe it's not such a
mystery anymore um Liz wolf is off this
week by the way so it'll be just me
talking with two people who've done way
more than most in advancing our
understanding of how the virus that
changed everything originated it's an
important question that I've thought at
many times we'd never get a satisfactory
answer to but this new information is
pretty revealing and remarkable and I
think tips the scales quite far in favor
of an explanation involving a lab
accident in Wuhan China the new
information was brought to light by
Emily cop a science and health reporter
with the nonprofit Public Health
Watchdog group us right to know who's
been doggedly pursuing and obtaining
documents related to this question for
years now Emily thank you for joining us
today Emily I think you're muted sorry
thanks for having me all right great um
also here is Alex wber a mathematical
biologist who's applied his training and
expertise to study and publish uh about
the evolution and spread of covid and
who co-authored a paper that will talk
about that had some of its predictions
seemingly validated by some of these new
documents Emily recently published Alex
thank you for joining us as well thank
you for having me here sure um I want to
start with a discussion of these new
documents uh you obtained
on January and published on January 18th
Emily uh under the headline let me pull
this up here uh us scientists proposed
to make viruses with unique features of
SARS COV 2 in Wuhan uh first off Emily
just tell us exactly what these new
documents are and why you were seeking
them in the first
place sure so this all started back in
2021 when the independent research group
drastic obtained um a leaked copy of
this diffuse Grant
proposal um to DARPA proposing to do
controversial viral
experimentation and in the years since
that major Revelation there's been a lot
of debate um between people who favor
the xenosis theory and people who favor
the lab leak Theory about what exactly
these documents mean the language in um
that proposal was highly technical um
and so there was a lot of nitpicking
about whether this Revelation was truly
um relevant to the origins of covid and
I just wanted to learn more about it um
and it just so happened that a public
institution USGS was a collaborator on
this Grant and so I submitted a to USGS
just hoping to learn more information um
and it took one and a half years or so
of nagging USGS to finally um get them
to turn over the documents um and so we
obtained them in
December uh I think the first major
Revelation um out of those documents is
that in a draft of this uh proposal
there were comments in the margins
suggesting that the work would not uh be
conducted in the US under a
bsl3 um relatively rigorous bio safety
standard but instead would be exported
to Wuhan um and be conducted under a
bsl2 which is just inadequate for
airborne viruses um so that was sort of
the major Revelation and we wanted to
get that out as soon as possible because
Congress was deliberating whether to
continue to allow Eco Health Alliance to
obtain um funds from the Pentagon um and
then we uh took about another month for
the other um remaining 1,200 documents
um which were
essentially minutes and drafts of The
Proposal that were a bit more candid
about the work that they intended to do
um and so it it cleared up a lot of the
confusion about the more technical
language and the formal proposal um and
just included more details about the the
intended
research and you you mentioned this uh
the the organization that you were
writing to to request these documents
was
USGS what is that and what do they have
to do with
virology yeah it's the US Geological
Survey um and their participation on the
proposal had to do with immunizing bats
with some of these chimeric Spike
proteins um I consider that to be sort
of ancillary to the core questions about
the origins of covid really it was just
my way of trying to be creative and get
the documents in a roundabout way given
that it's a public institution um and
given our ongoing struggles to get
documents out of um Barrack's Lab at
UNCC so um yeah it's just uh it's just
always strange when these like seemingly
random government organizations are
somehow involved I I mean I guess
geological the US Geological Survey bats
live in caves is that like the the
connection here uh to
to to to the issue at hand I don't know
but uh I do want to bring um up this
document uh that you know this is the
proposal that uh you're investigating
it's known as uh project
diffuse um and uh it's essentially a
proposal to DARPA the Defense Agency uh
to collect and manipulate bat viruses
ostensibly for the purpose of predicting
what kind of viruses might jump from
bats to humans and cause future
pandemics uh and you summarize one of
their proposals this way that the
scientists sought to insert fur and
cleavage sites at the S1 S2 Junction of
the spike
protein to assemble synthetic uh viruses
in six segments to identify Corona
viruses up to 25% different from SARS
and to select for receptor binding
domains Adept at infecting human
receptors and then you go with these
bullet points and you list kind of one
by one the
characteristics that SARS COV 2 the ways
in which it matches the viruses that are
described in this proposal so SARS COV 2
has a fur and cleavage site which we has
been discussed at length and we can talk
about a little bit more later uh SARS
COV 2 can be divided into six contiguous
genomic Pieces by the restriction
enzymes uh bsal and
bmbl um and orders for one of those
enzymes BML can be found in the
documents and the receptor binding
domain appeared finally tuned for human
ace2 receptor uh and then the genome has
the genetic differences from SARS
um so here's where I want to bring in
Alex to help explain the significance of
their plans to assemble the viruses
specifically in those six segments using
some very specific enzymes could you
explain that for us a little bit more
deeply Alex absolutely one kind of
interesting backstory is that the
diffuse Grant was proposed to the DARPA
preempt call in 2018 and I had submitted
or helped write in a
success as well so this call is very
intimately familiar to me and um in that
context what was distinct about diffuse
was their search for this Motif that had
never been seen in the SARS Corona virus
before the fear and cleavage site and
their proposal to insert this thing that
had never been seen before in the SARS
Coronavirus
and so the proposal to insert a f and
cleavage site instantly puts them down a
particular laboratory path so how do you
insert a f and cleavage site into a SARS
Corona virus the SARS Corona virus has
this RNA genome which you can think of
this really flimsy film of a genetic
strand of RNA and it breaks very easily
it's very hard to insert motifs inside
of an RNA genome so if you want to
insert a fur in cleavage site you have
to build this much sturdier DNA copy of
the virus
and in order to build a sturdy DNA copy
of the virus you have to build it one
block at a time we looked into the preco
well I guess not not we but Valentine
brutel and Tony van dongan had looked
these are bio Engineers Valentine in
University of rburg and Tony aduk
University um they're bioengineers they
build these DNA blocks um from scratch
so they looked into the methods for how
people did this in Corona viruses preo
and found that one of the most common
methods for building these fulllength
DNA clones of a virus was to order these
blocks and nip them at the end with
these restriction sites that allow you
to attach them one at a time until
eventually you have that full length DNA
clone and one of the diffused P really
popularized this this technique Ralph
baric wrote a paper on efficient reverse
genetic systems well that's a lot of
words it just means reverse genetics is
you have this DNA clone that you're
tinkering with to make these different
RNA viruses and the process
experimenting with the role between
these genes and the and the
manipulations of these genes like if
you're in cleavage site on the function
of the virus um so that was kind of the
context we looked into this diffuse
proposal and asked okay if they're
inserting a feum cleavage site they need
a full length clone if you're building a
full length D clone they're probably
using methodologies like those that
Ralph baric popularized is there any
evidence for this in the SARS 2 genome
we studied a met we ran a meta analysis
of all these infectious clones and
reverse genetic systems made before
covid and found that they all had this
characteristic manner of manipulation
that researchers would look at the
Genome of the virus on the computer
screen look at where these cutting sites
are and they move them around a little
bit to make it easier to assemble these
blocks and they would move these cutting
sites around with these mutations called
Silent mutations that change the genetic
sequence without changing the resulting
virus so researchers before covid would
make these full length DNA clones by
using silent mutations to move these
cutting sites that form these little
notches that you can use to attach
chunks of DNA together to build that
full length clone we looked into that
and found that SARS 2 had this very
unusual pattern of evenly spaced cutting
sites um that was consistent with how
people built reverse genetic systems
before covid and that when you look
closer at these cutting sites yeah this
is the figure here those cutting sites
BSM 1 and bsa1 typically are randomly
spaced throughout the genome when you
have randomly spaced things they don't
often come with fragments of this
similar size but when you look at this
visually Valentine and Tony had just
screamed at them this is unusual and
they have much they have a lot of
experience seeing what you see in the
the other so SARS k 2 is the top row
here all the other viruses um you know
from V now 20 247 to SARS
one their BSM and bsa1 sites are
randomly scattered and that's what you
typically see when you upload a genome
into this software that helps you see
the cutting sites Valentine and Tony
uploaded SARS 2 saw this unusual pattern
and thought wow this is like an Ikea
virus you know this is something you
could just order right from scratch and
get this allen wrench of BS smb1 and
this screwdriver of bsa1 and Stitch it
together so the question then was what
are the odds of this occurring in nature
and that's where I came in as a
mathematical biologist to study the
evolution of Corona virus and tried to
get an estimate on the odds of
disappearing in nature given that it is
so consistent with a reverse genetic
system we found those odds were really
low so when you the way we estimated it
was looking at this longest fragment
length so this top figure here the Y AIS
is the length of the longest fragment
from cutting up a virus with any one or
any pair of these enzymes and then the
x-axis is a number of fragments when
Ralph baric wrote his paper on efficient
reverse genetic systems he proposed that
box is this idealized range for an
efficient reverse genetic system
somewhere between five to eight
fragments and ideally less than 8,000
base pairs long for the longest fragment
because when you order these chunks of
DNA online um 8,000 base pairs is a
common cut off now that said the longer
the fragment is the more the more likely
it is to either contain a toxic element
that prevents your ability to replicate
it and clone it and make a lot of it um
and it also reduces usces the odds of
faithful assembly when you have a really
long Wiggly piece of DNA it may not
attach as Faithfully or at high of rate
um as shorter fragments so there's a
preference to have smaller fragments in
general and that's what really was the
lurking lab protocol constraints that
led to this pattern of unusually even
spacing in these restriction sites so we
looked at the we Quantified the odds of
seeing something as or more extremis SS
too just in the pattern the spacing of
these sites and that was about a one in
event um so one out of 14,000 this is
actually the most extreme case of a
coronav virus that we've seen for these
enzymes that can be used for the
Assembly of these reverse genetic
systems then we look further at the
silent mutations that's where we found
hot spots like glowing genetic dust
right on these specific sites and
wherever they were moved around they
were moved around exclusively with the
mutations bioengineers use and that was
our most significant
finding and so this is what you know the
title of your paper is uh
endonuclear print uh indicates a
synthetic origin of sarov 2 so the
fingerprint that you're referring to
there is essentially the fact that there
are let me pull up that figure one more
time these rather
evenly uh spaced like somewhat regularly
L length uh segments as opposed to in a
naturally occurring virus you would get
uh much you'd get much more variation in
the length you'd get some really short
ones and some really long ones um and so
it's just mathematically unusual for
that or you know maybe even
mathematically impossible or highly
improbable that that would occur in
nature so would this be um so this would
be different from we've heard a lot of
discussion about gain of function
research where you would um one method
in sort of in enhancing the deadliness
of a virus for humans would be to pass
it through mice so it kind of naturally
you know not naturally but in the lab
you're kind of forcing an evolution
towards deadliness you're positing that
that is not how this virus was created
in in lab was more of a kind of cut and
paced situation well in order to conduct
there's many so yeah some we break up
some terms here the gain of function
some biologists like to kind of Muddy
The Waters by saying ah well you know
anytime you modify an organism like add
a basilo theous toxin to Corn which
helps us have the corn have this natural
pesticide produced in it they would say
oh well that's gain of function because
it gained the function that it didn't
have before so some people split hairs
and say there's a different kind of gain
of function called gain of function
research of concern which is the
enhancement of the transmissibility and
or virulence of potentially pandemic
pathogens this gain of function research
of concern concerned started in 2011
when Ron fusier took an Aven influenza
which was very infectious in birds and
had a 50% infection fatality rate and
then he passaged it through a bunch of
fets until he he produced by this
breeding experiment that was intended to
produce a virus that was more
transmissible in mammals that didn't
exist in nature so that's this gain of
function research of concern and the
DARPA the diffuse proposal I want to
give credit to DARPA they invented the
internet and they rejected the diffuse
so it's a diffuse proposal of interest
you know diffuse proposal reveals the
intentions of these researchers who
previously had conducted a lot of gain
of function research of concern they
would find these bat Corona viruses
lurking in nature and they would swap
around these parts of the B thatat coron
virus is making these chimeras to then
ask oh which Chimera is the most
infectious in people and that question
is modifying things found in nature to
improve their transmissibility and the
intention their search was for something
more transmissible so you would expect
this research program to result in
something more transmissible because
that's what they were trying to make and
the fear and cleavage site specifically
was well known before covid that fear
and cleavage sites are found in other
viruses and when they're found in other
viruses they're kind of this master key
that allow the virus to unlock all sorts
of different host cells and enter into
bat cells and human cells and dogs and
whatever um so the fear and cleavage
site was this master key why would you
give that to a SARS Corona virus that's
anticipated to improve the
transmissibility of this virus possibly
improve the virulence as well if the
virus is able to infect more tissues
within the human body so that the
insertion of the fear and cleavage site
was the gain of function research of
concern and that's just to just to be
really uh clear for our listeners who
may not have been following every detail
of this the the fur and cleavage site
the reason that there's so much
attention on it is because a um it is th
this SARS COV 2 is the only virus in its
category the of these SARS likee Corona
viruses that has it and B that makes it
particular humans uh particularly
susceptible to it it's it it eases the
entry into human cells is that more or
less the reason why the fear in cleavage
site was like the the first kind of red
flag for people who thought that this
might have originated in a lab that's
exactly right if you're in cleavage site
had never been observed before aars
Corona virus and we when we buildt The
evolutionary tree of aar's coron viruses
before covid we had a thousand years of
branches in this tree and there wasn't a
single indication that a SARS Corona
virus existed anywhere in that tree yet
they were very prominent in the minds of
urologists and this is where I can speak
as you know someone who is in that DARPA
preempt community of accepted grants
that we all knew that the biggest Crux
for these jump capable quasi species the
biggest Crux for host switching is
binding onto the receptors of a new host
because new hosts have very different
funky receptors in their cells so how
can a virus latch onto that and enter
into the cell the fear and cleide
assists with that process and it was
known to assist with that process so
virologists everywhere were looking for
these things because they really wanted
to find them if you found a Fe and
cleavage site in for instance an
influenza virus that passed through a
chicken farm which they did once in one
chicken farm out of all the chicken
farms that had been infected with this
that was documented and there was explos
news because biologists understood the
context so the fear and cleavage site
was a motif this master key that
biologists knew about but nature didn't
or nature knew about it would stumble
upon it randomly but had not stumbled
upon it in the 10,000 years of SARS
coronavirus Evolution that we've seen
yet then we find aars coronav virus with
this master key in Wuhan exactly where
researchers proposed to give it to aars
Corona virus so that's the fear and
cleavage site that's the gain of
function research of concern component
and our work was focused more on the
laboratory
protocols that they had said they wanted
to find all these Wildlife Corona
viruses so we usually go out you catch a
bat you sample its poop or its mouth or
whatever and then you send that into a
lab and you sequence it when you
sequence it you get this long genetic
code 30,000 base pairs on a computer now
how can you go from that genetic code to
then saying ah this virus is more likely
to infect people or less likely to
infect people for that we use all these
laboratory techniques to construct parts
of the virus or higher viruses and our
work was focused on that both the
rescuing of viruses from a genetic
sequence using these reverse genetic
systems or infectious clones and that
that's a really remarkable thing to
think about is that most viruses go from
a virus to cell to a virus to cell to
virus to cell and you can trace that
back in time infinite indefinitely to
the origins of the virus but infectious
clones they go from a virus to a cell to
a poop sample in a bat to a genome on a
computer screen and then from that
genome on a computer screen we order
these blocks and Stitch them together
and then we make from that DNA clone
this RNA we electrocute a cell to form
these holes in it an electroporated cell
and shove that RNA inside the cell it
starts making a virus it's this sort of
Immaculate Conception of modern
biotechnology and that was the most
common way of rescuing Corona viruses
from these Wildlife samples um where you
could have the genome but you may not
have cultured the virus the virus may
have died while it was being transported
to a lab but you can still get the
genome you could still get the virus you
could still study it and that
methodology was also inuse but it was a
bit more Technical and subtle to find
these fingerprints in the genome but
that's what we found so um Alex's paper
made certain predictions um about you
know
what what uh scientists would have done
uh to you know what you would expect to
see in their work if this were a
synthetic virus if an infectious
clone what uh to bring it back to the
documents
Emily what do the doc how do the
documents work in conjunction with
Alex's work uh when you look at them
side by side what are what are some of
the consistencies or inconsistencies
that jumped out to
you yeah so first of all just to follow
up on some of the things that Alex
mentioned so I think the more candid
notes we have about the diffuse proposal
show that their intention was to
generate viruses that could generate
disease in um humanized mice that was
the so-called gold standard that's how
Peter daik put it in the um meeting
minutes from one of their calls together
um so
so the methods that they were um using
to get to that gold standard um may have
included the the technique that um Alex
described but I think that part is
somewhat controversial whereas there are
some notes that we obtained that
confirm that other features of SARS Ki 2
that immediately stood out to people as
a sign of Engineering in the lab were
really Central to the research interests
of that Pi he mentioned Ralph baric sort
of the top virologist focusing on Corona
virus in the world um so he intended to
create a model um in order to generate
viruses that could cause disease in
humanized mice and two of the key
features that he screened for with that
model or intended to screen for with
that model um were a fur in cleavage
site you know particularly a fur in
cleavage site at the S1 S2 boundary in
the spike protein and a receptor binding
domain that was very good at latching on
to human Ace 2 um
and maybe that's not um maybe that
doesn't grab people right away if you're
not super familiar with the debate
around the origins of covid but really
people have been talking about SARS k2's
immediate ability to um latch on to
human Ace to from the beginning it's a
immediate ability to be very
transmissible and infectious and go on
to infect pretty much everyone on the
globe um and people have been talking
about that fear and cleav site from the
beginning as a u signal of engineering
so um I think those two elements are
also very important to focus on
um also just you know as Alex mentioned
people were very interested in fearing
cleavage sites around the time of the
diffuse proposal when that was submitted
and in fact in doing this reporting I
went back and I watched some of the
debate around gain of function research
back in 2014
um when there was a a pause on gain a
function research of concern and uh NIH
was hosting debates about what sort of
Regulation should be in place and baric
was obviously an opponent of regulations
um at least for Corona viruses which was
his interest and a lot of the questions
that he and his colleagues got were
around okay so what would be a
permissible experiment would inserting a
fear and cleavage site would that be
permissible um and so obviously this was
on people's minds and so um as someone
who was not familiar with that debate
and was not tracking that debate at the
time um it was surprising to me to go
back and watch because obviously when a
virus with a fear and cleavage site
appeared in Wuhan the the lab working
closely with baric no one said oh yes
we've been discussing this for years um
so so anyway so
so with uh with regard to the
Restriction sites so the documents do
include a budget line for
bsmbi um which is one of the Restriction
sites that make up that pattern that
Alex and his colleagues described um but
there is some debate
about is that a budget for the entire
project or is that just a budget for the
USGS component how C is that budget line
too yeah well let me bring up I've got a
so this is a tweet from Richard ebite
who was one of the um virologists who
was kind of I mean one of the earliest
people I remember raising this
possibility of it being a lab leak um
and he calls this this invoice for this
particular enzyme that Alex mentions in
his study this is an order form of for
it and he calls it the equivalent of a
Smoking Gun on the other hand Alina Chan
who is another uh someone who's been
very uh uh um sort of putting out the
idea of that this could have been
allowed leak for a long time we've had
her on the show before she co-authored a
whole book uh about the origins of covid
with Matt Ridley called viral um and
she's not convinced yet she says there
isn't enough yet to say a lab accident
happened Beyond A Reasonable Doubt uh
mostly because the emails and documents
we're talking about are from early 2018
so therefore it's unsurprising there's
not any direct evidence of you know a
line from this this order to the
creation of SARS COV 2 you know I guess
an an open question that I have for both
of you is how should we evaluate
evidence and like when when is the
appropriate time to say you know case
closed this is you know this is the
Smoking Gun we can pretty much say at
this point we're never going to get 100%
certainty but beyond A Reasonable Doubt
looks like something something happened
here something was
constructed I'm happy to jump in here I
think you know what I was doing before
Co was specifically forecasting which
species are Quasi species that are junk
capable what's the likelihood of that
emerging where is it likely to emerge
um and what does that look like and we
all have actually seen a recent example
of a natural spillover with the Aven
influenza outbreaks that happened last
year many people got infected and You'
see these stuttering chains of
transmission because exactly as Emily
said the virus was not very
transmissible when it first jumped into
the human population and so for me what
jumped out is like you know we'll put
the line way over here for case closed
and then there's a line way over here
for open the books and I think we cross
opened the books line immediately when
SARS K2 emerged it had a receptor
binding domain that was better at
binding humans than bats that's a really
unusual feature for a bat Corona virus
viruses specialize on their host they
get these very specific moldings so
their Spike genes The receptors of their
host The receptors of bats are different
from humans so this should be molded to
a bat but instead it looked more molded
to a human than a bat so that was
immediately a very strange occurrence
that it didn't have this m multiple
spillover events across a wide
Geographic range consistent with the
animal trade outbreak of SARS one there
were not infections concentrated in
animal handlers like we saw in civit
handlers in SARS one or in poultry
Farmers for Aven influenza instead it
was this singular outbreak that just
exploded immediately out of Wuhan with a
SARS Corona virus whose receptor binding
domain was better fit for humans than
bats that had a fearing cleavage site
that as someone again in this Wildlife
orology community I knew that many
virologists were fixated on Fair and
cleavage sites this was something that
virologists thought a lot about but when
you look at the data in nature nature
did not stumble upon it that often
instead when it happened we Lo made a
big deal out of it wrote big papers
about it and everyone was aware of it
but nature was not and so for me it was
we crossed the line to open the books
almost immediately at the start of the
pandemic but there's never been that
that's never seemed to have been the
attitude um you know
opening the books uh it would what would
follow from that is you know open
scientific this is a this is an
empirical question it's so that that
requires open scientific inquiry but I
you know I think to kind of capture the
tone of that we can just look at these
tweets from uh Christian Anderson who
was uh one of the authors on the famous
proximal Origins paper that uh proposed
that this jump from pangolins to humans
uh that Pengalin were the intermediate
host and then um it was revealed through
documents that he had these kind of this
back Channel with Anthony fouchy who was
sort of guiding that project the entire
time but his reaction to your uh
pre-print Alex was that uh it is so
deeply flawed that it wouldn't pass
kindergarten molecular biology it's more
of the same poppycock dressed up as
science with a heavy dose of
technobabble on the side and you know
you don't have to reply to that kind of
name calling though you can if you want
what I'd like to know is um what are the
challenges for dissenting scientists at
this point in examining the this
question obviously there's been
challenges along the way but like at
this point do you feel that your paper
could even get a fair peer review or is
the process self kind of
compromise well a couple points here one
yeah the feedback from Christian
Anderson was not the most constructive
feedback we
received um another little aside my mom
was a molecular biologist so in
kindergarten I was doing some you know
listening about DNA at the table but not
that much admittedly um and then finally
you know a lab origin involves a lab and
the lab involves researchers and
researchers are in this network of
colleagues and funders and so when we
pass this open the books phase very
early on in the pandemic we would have
liked to hear about for example the
diffuse proposal but did we hear about
the diffuse proposal no we didn't um did
we hear the niid had actually funded the
unique collaboration of the diffuse pis
in 2019 no we didn't instead Anthony
fouchy helped prompt that proximal
origin paper Peter dasac the pi of
diffuse wrote a paper to the Lancet
calling lab origin theories conspiracy
theories without acknowledging the
conflict of interest that he was working
with the lab in question that he wrote
the diffused proposal containing a
highly specific proposal to make
something not found in nature something
so unnatural that you could have
patented it in 2018 and SARS KOB 2 would
be an infringement of their patent
that's a very important conflict of
interest he should have disclosed when
we were at the open the books phase in
January of 2020 and he didn't in fact we
also have emails of Peter dasac writing
the fellow colleagues of the pi of the
fellow pis of the diffuse proposal in an
email titled no need for you to sign the
statement Ralph to exclamation marks and
in that email Peter daac says that he
they proposes that they don't sign this
the pis who propos to make this unique
product not found in nature which
mirrors SARS kobe2 to the letter um they
proposed to not sign this late statement
calling lab origin theories conspiracy
theories dasac was then appointed the US
Emissary to the World Health
organization's Co Origins investigation
in Wuhan and he didn't disclosed the
fuse to the world then he was appointed
to lead the lancet's covid origin task
force by Jeffrey saaks and he didn't
disclose it then instead he appointed
all of his close colleagues who also had
conflicts of interest in their work with
the Wuhan Labs as fellow investigators
of this lab origin accident when Jeffrey
saak started turning over Stones he
found conflicts of interest everywhere
and so at the heart of a lab origin is a
lab and researchers and the unfortunate
thing we're seeing here is that many of
the researchers and their funders have
these very tight connections to the
Wuhan Institute of biology I happened to
be one of the people who was working on
a DARPA preent Grant in this field
without any connections to the Wuhan
Institute of iology and also at the time
of writing this paper I wasn't in
Academia I wasn't writing grants niid I
was an independent scientific consultant
and that made me somewhat immune to
Christian Anderson's Tweets in this
sense you know I was really focused on
the question at
hand yeah I'm I'm really it's the the
role of sort of Institutions and people
who are independent of those
institutions in this is a really
important and interesting aspect of how
this is all played out and I'm curious
about your thoughts on it too Emily
because from a media perspective you're
working for an organization us right to
know that operates outside of the
mainstream media ecosystem it's an
organization that to be honest I was a
little wary of because think there's
some fundamental disagreements in how
the editorial leadership looks at things
like GMOs or the Green Revolution but I
honestly think your work speaks for
itself on this topic which is largely
consists of obtaining and Reporting on
government documents in a pretty
straightforward manner it's odd to me
that more Publications haven't picked up
on these documents what do you make of
the media environment at this point as
it pertains to the investigation into
CO's
Origins yeah I think before I start
ranting about the media just to follow
up on a couple of the things that um
Alex was mentioning I think in addition
to the scientific evidence that we dug
up and that he dug up I think it's also
important to look at the behavioral
Clues here and the odd um actions of
people sort of central to the coron
virus research going on in Wuhan after
SAR kov 2 emerge from that city um
including the fact that Beric was
working on this model that was meant to
predict whether a Corona virus could
cause disease in humanized mice using um
you know the receptor binding domain's
ability to bind to human Ace 2 and fear
and cleavage sites and then when SARS
kov 2 with this these unique features
showed up did not raise his hand to say
I actually have a model you know I've
been studying this for years um you know
for sure yeah absolutely yes and um and
why did daik continue to insist for
years that this work would go on at the
University of North Carolina under a
bsl3 when clearly he knew you know he
wrote this comment saying that in fact
this work would be outsourced to the
Wuhan Institute of Urology and would be
conducted under bsl2 yeah let me pull
that up uh this is from those those
documents so uh yeah you you got the the
annotated comments on um their proposal
and so here you've got uh um Peter daak
saying that you know if we win the
contract I am not proposing that all the
work will necessarily be conducted by
Ralph baric in North Carolina but he
wants to stress the US side of the
proposal to DARPA so that they're
comfortable in in other words he wants
to play Down the fact that as he said
says a lot of these this work can be
done in Wuhan um and then further down
you've got Ralph baric uh talking about
their proposal to in China do this in a
biocurity level two rather than the
higher biocurity level three that would
be expected the US and he says that you
know um if they're they're growing those
in under bsl2 in China us researchers
will likely freak out and so yeah there
really that it's very revealing of the
the the mindset and and the culture of
like I mean these are people who have a
a really serious responsibility of
handling a virus that can kill lots of
people and just dis re societal
destruction and they're kind of like
what can we slip past DARPA and and
again luckily DARPA did not approve this
particular Grant but it does say a lot
about kind of the atmosphere uh what
what was the the Cavalier attitude of
the scientists that are are working with
these these really deadly uh da
dangerous viruses but Emily uh continue
with your your explanation of the the
psychology and then if you could also
talk a little bit about the media
coverage of uh the lab League at
present yeah I mean I think your your
spot on there I mean bar said that us
researchers would freak out about this
work being outsourced to bsl2 in China
before uh you know virus um started
circulating the globe um out of Wuhan so
um of course he knew people would freak
out about this um and instead of doing
what I think would be the moral
patriotic thing and being transparent um
and coming forward uh they attempted to
save their own reputations and clearly
made a bet that these documents would
never come out and so he kept lying to
his sources in um in media and lying to
other scientists that this work was to
be done in um more rigorous bios safety
standards of the US and he knew that to
be a lie um he also said that they
didn't sample in LA and that was also a
lie you know some of SARS kov 2's
closest relative circulate in southeast
China so that's highly relevant
information to the origins of covid um
and people looked in genbank and said it
says that this this was sampled in La
what's going on um and our documents
also confirm their intention to sample
there so um so the behavior is very
strange the Lancet letter organizing
that and telling Ralph baric to leave
his name off um it's you know I think
that speaks volumes as well and then
also I did want to answer your original
question about what is what would
constitute kind of final firm evidence
I think the um the research described
and the documents that we and drastic
obtained um probably describe how SARS k
2 became SARS kov 2 but we don't know
what viruses they were starting with we
don't know at the time they were
exchanging these notes and having these
conversations if they had sampled SARS
K2 like viruses at that point um you
know we know a uh have identified rg13
one of SARS K 2's closest relatives um
but I think we need to know more
information about that but if we were to
confirm that they were doing using some
of the techniques described in these
documents with SARS K2 like viruses I
think that would be I mean as close to
like a final Smoking Gun as you could
get um so but yeah it's
seems very likely that uh let's say that
the Chinese government had that
information that there's almost no
chance that would ever come out well one
quick point on that there was an email
Peter dasac sent to his US based
colleagues in April of 2020 with the
subject line China gen Bank sequences
gen bank is where we deposit our
sequences and then the importance of
this email was high in that email Peter
daac said to his colleagues let's not
upload these China gen Bank sequences
they were part of the terminated ni ID
grant that same grant that brought
together diffus collaborators in 2019
and dasac mentioned that if you did
publish these sequences it would bring
very unwelcome attention to USA predict
UC Davis and other colleagues on this
email so it's possible the digital
signatures of this work still exist out
there or have been deleted or scrubbed
in a deliberate effort by dasak to not
bring unwelcome attention to he and his
collaborators
absolutely and of course you know the
WAN Institute of rology took its
database offline so again sort of the
behavioral Clues here um suggest that
there could be something to hide and
we've submitted uh foyer requests to ni
um which hosts the repositories for
these sequences um for metadata that
could hopefully shed light on um that
deleted data um but yeah so is this
where I rant about the media well well
let me let me yeah let me bring this
back to the media question for a second
because you know one one example that
really comes to mind for me and how that
their um the sort of treatment because
it's not like uh the New York Times has
not covered the idea of a lab leak at
all or other uh large prestigious
organizations it's just that there's a
sort of a symmetry because I think it
goes back to the
this network that you're talking about
it's it's it's kind of understandable
you have respectable scientists saying
one thing they might have motives for
saying that thing but then that is what
gets treated as more credible right out
of the gate and like one striking
example to me was the way that this this
is a New York Times article on the
preprint uh on the kind of definitive
paper that's making the argument that
this uh spillover from animals to humans
happened at the Hunan Market New
research points to Wuhan Market as
pandemic origin and kind of the the way
this was reported you could see a quote
from Michael warie one of the lead
authors on it when you look at the
evidence Al together it's an
extraordinarily clear picture that the
pandemic started in the Hunan Market
some of those conclusions were softened
a little bit once this went through peer
review uh notes there that it at the
time of publication in the New York
Times it had not yet been published in a
scientific journal um I I I do want to
like you know talk a little bit about
like the the way that was covered but
also about the study itself um maybe
Alex could weigh in in on this um
they're arguing that the the the the
argument of the paper is they did
samples uh in the market and you can see
in this diagram there's a little red hot
spot where they're saying most of the
virus was uh
transmitted uh or or you know the hot
spot of viral samples was in this little
corner like one or two stalls and then
if you zoom in on that you'll see
they've got you know these two stalls
kind of highlighted in red and they've
got pictures of raccoon dogs and uh
unknown Birds these uh ma basically
mammals that plausibly could have
transmitted the virus from um uh two
human beings in the market and and
kicked this pandemic off what uh this is
the this and one other paper who was was
by many of the same authors are kind of
like the touchstones for like th this is
the definitive argument for zuntic spill
over of the virus which which is which
is a very common way for pandemics to
start what is your analysis uh in short
of of this paper
Alex I if you could keep up that figure
that's actually a great great touch
Point um so this analysis made a
statistical error and the error fails to
account for sampling biases um if you
look at that little gradiation of number
of environmental positives at the middle
kind of near the bottom there that's the
statistic that they were analyzing and
so yeah it looks like there's a high
number of environmental positives in
this um low lower left quadrant however
we we pointed out that the Chinese
researchers who conducted this work said
in their methods they are prioritizing
samples near animal stalls so they took
more samples that's why there's a higher
number of samples if you look at the
percent of samples that test positive
they were actually highest near
vegetable Traders and in the toilet in
the sewage which tells a very different
epidemiological story of human to human
transmission and another point to you
know on the broader um topic of War it
out they looked at where are cases found
within the city of Wuhan and they said
ah well these cases found within the
city of Wuhan with asterisk cases
provided by the Chinese government were
centralized localized around the Wuhan
the huan seafood market however when you
do a statistical analysis of those data
you find that the unlined cases um are
actually closer to the seafood market
which suggests that these cases did have
this bias and case ascertainment
furthermore there were Cases left out of
this analysis cases that preceded the
wet Market outbreak for instance a
December 4th report of a SARS coronav
virus case in Wuhan that coincided with
an uptick of the use of the word SARS in
the Chinese social media app weebo so
that those two data points corroborate
this case preceding the wet Market
outbreak and furthermore there's another
analysis of these care- seeking terms
that are less likely to have been
filtered which showed that the earlier
hot spot of care seeking term usage in
Wuhan was on the other side of the river
near a hospital that's one of the
closest hospitals to the Wuhan Institute
of biology so when we try to look at
these independent lines to corroborate
this and when we account for the
statistical biases their findings don't
hold their claim of dispositive evidence
hasn't lasted the test of time so that's
the warbow paper and most of us who are
in the field knew that right away David
rman called this hopelessly impoverished
early case data um and it was quite
evident that that was the case so for us
scientists in the field it's unusual
that these two papers
the other one had similar statistical
flaws and a bug in its code that
completely undermined it these two
papers were both published side by side
in science and then both presented in
the New York Times and the Atlantic and
the guardian as you know dispositive
evidence it's been solved and for many
of us scientists especially me familiar
with the standards of evidence in the
field before covid for instance looking
at the percent of PCR tests that are
positive which we all know was a big
debate during covid in terms of how to
measure prevalence in the population um
to control for increasing rates of
testing you know for us who are familiar
with the standards of evidence and the
common modes of analysis in the field
these papers were highly unusual so was
the proximal origin paper by these same
authors and then you trace it back to
the wall and you find that Anthony
fouchy who funded the diffused pis in
2019 he prompted this call he put the
people in the room and who did he put in
the room with Christian Anderson Edy
Holmes he put in the leading proponents
of gain of function research including
the OG Ron Fier who passaged that Aven
influenza through ferrets so this was
you know it's like the EPA calling in
all the oil and gas companies when
they're presented with a study finding
evidence of climate change you know when
us scientists who are familiar with the
other scientists and the debates in the
field and the methods and modes of
analysis when we see this it's just a it
that to me is Raising alarm bells in
addition to the genomic evidence of the
fear and cleavage site not just any fear
and cleavage site you know but feing
cleavage site in the exact position
where Emily's recently foa documents
proposed to insert it um in Wuhan where
this was proposed to be conducted and
far from the Hotpot of thatat SARS
Corona viruses and a Litany of other
evidence that all combines and I think
for me that's how I think of the
evidence is we have to treat these
zootic origin papers methodically and
look at them carefully and see how much
evidence they do provide once we throw
those off the table based on their
statistical flaws and other other
problems with them all that's left is
this mountain of evidence you know it's
like the straw that broke the camel's
back we're looking for that straw but
we're forgetting about the many bales of
hay that are already there and that's
you know our paper was yet another straw
but Emily is right to point out and
thinking about this evidence you have to
look at everything you have to look at
the Wuhan origin the fur and cleavage
site at the S1 S2 Junction with these
weird codons bioengineers use with all
this weird Behavior both of the Chinese
government and the researchers connected
with the Wuhan labs and coincidentally
we found evidence consistent with the
exact method for assembly that they
proposed and that every time we foil new
documents we only get closer to the
truth that corroborates this Theory
we've had all
along so what does this all say about
the state of science journalism uh
Emily Emily do you want to take that
I've got opinions but I feel like you
have some good ones too yeah um I feel
like I could rant about this all day but
I think just taking the war be
as an example um I mean some of the
stuff we're discussing is very high
level and maybe the journalist just
didn't understand you might say but
remember that at the point that that
pre-print came out and the New York
Times push alerted it the senior authors
of that paper had been caught lying
already we already had the Foyd emails
showing that Anderson said that the SARS
K2 genome had features consistent with
engineering and then four days later
told the nationaly that um that that was
a crank Theory um and we already knew
that Robert Gary another author on that
paper um had said I can't figure out how
this Spike protein gets accomplished in
nature but it would be easy to do in a
lab and then you know a few days later
started drafting a paper that would
dismiss the idea of engineering as a
conspiracy theory so these people were
already not credible you know and Zach
you were talking about how you know
people's default is often well this
person has a lot of expertise they're
affiliated with this prestigious
institution they seem the the most
credible and um in 99% of cases I would
agree but I think we're in this unique
situation where we're trusting
virologists to give us straight answer
straight answers about whether a
pandemic that killed millions of people
stemmed from controversial biology
research
um and you know these virologists in
particular already at this point had a
track record of
dishonesty um and I think when you're a
reporter I think you have to have some
healthy
skepticism
and you know Prestige is important
expertise is important but so is
integrity and I remember when this you
know paper got a lot of attention in the
press I mean the New York Times alerted
it CNN alerted it a bunch of other news
organizations I remember thinking you
know does honesty not matter does
integrity not matter um I think it
clearly matters and um you
know another aspect here um that should
have alerted journalists to
something strange going on was the fact
that I mean literally hours before the
war be pre-print published the China CDC
had come out with its own analysis um in
a preprint of this data and they had
concluded that the wet Market was a
super spreader event that it had just
Amplified an already existing epidemic
um you know that conclusion happens to
um be consistent with their country's
propaganda around the pandemic starting
somewhere else but they did collect the
data um and they have more knowledge
about how they collected their own data
than Western scientists working on
laptops many miles away and what they
said was exactly what Alex just said
which is that you know these samples
that appear to Cluster around the animal
stalls we actually focused our our
collection efforts there um and Jesse
Bloom has analyzed the metagenomic data
and found that um animal DNA
specifically animals that could have
served as inter mediate hosts like
raccoon dogs um is uh not correlated
with SARS
K2 virus um and so those samples are not
very meaningful which China CDC knew and
said right before um The New York Times
put on its front page that it was
definitely the wet market and the labl
theory is a conspiracy theory um and I
think the more information we've gotten
um um the less and less these papers
have stood up recently two experts in
spatial statistics put out a paper
basically saying that the war be paper
is extremely flawed um but there hasn't
been a lot of followup that I've seen in
the western media at least to correct
the record and to also look at some of
the evidence that's accumulated on the
lab side so um there's a lack of like
followup also
you know uh Alex when Emily talks about
integrity that is it's just so striking
to go back to that docu the annotated
document where you've got um you've got
uh Peter daak saying we're going to just
downplay or you know conceal the fact
that most of this very risky research is
going to be taking place in China um the
the the attitude that's on display that
we talked about a little bit earlier do
you have any thoughts about what can be
done to change the culture the mindset
that is on display there as someone who
has worked in this world of pursuing
government contracts uh or you know
DARPA grants uh in
barology well I think one give credit to
DARPA words do that they rejected this
proposal that they saw through this
unsafe research proposed by daac and
they said no um but then you have to
look at niid that funded these diffused
collaborators in 2019 and then you
actually have to look back beyond that
to Ron fusier and you have to look at
you know the history of this pandemic
started in
2011 um most people are looking at you
know the wet market and January 2020 or
cases in late 2019 but this started in
2011 and that was the beginning of a
systemic seismic shift in this research
Community where many researchers were
outraged that r Fier not only did this
research that risked causing a pandemic
and killing millions of people but if it
was really bad it could end human
civilization and scientists spoke up
within our community and we said this is
not okay um please stop please halt This
research it's not worth the risk we're
not getting any material benefits
there's no treatments or vaccines coming
from this work stop it um but why didn't
we stop it and that goes back to these
2014 discussions that Emily's been
listening to and others as well where
there was this massive debate there was
this Cambridge working group of
scientists from Harvard and elsewhere
that were saying and Richard ebite and
David rman saying we need to stop this
the risk the benefit um does not
outweigh the risks of this work and then
there was a very political group called
scientists for science effectively the
boys will be boys of science that said
hey just let us do science we need to be
able to do this work because you never
know what benefits might lurk around the
corner but we know the risks lurk around
the corner and they are catastrophic and
and so the scientist for science who
signed that who were those people if you
look down that list you'll see a lot of
familiar names you'll see Ron fusier and
Christian dren who were um the two of
the people that fouie Farrar and Collins
invited into the room in February of
2020 you'll see Vincent rockano the host
of this week in barology whose student
Angela rasmusen has become this very
outspoken proponent of let scientists do
science let boys be boys you'll see
seven signatories who were members of
NIH and niid including David Moren who
Peter dasac described as a mentor and
David Moren was now shown to have been
withholding or to have been failing to
comply with Federal records um retention
requirements by using his Gmail account
to conduct official NIH business he's
since been removed from his post of NIH
but yet we still don't have his Gmail
Communications with his Mente Peter daac
who he was in communication with in 2019
so we have this very Sy IC shift in
science where
niid led by Anthony fouchy sided with
Scientists for science in this debate
between scientists so we had this King
maker of Anthony fouchi and Francis
Collins who saw this debate in science
and said we're goingon to work with
these people and in fact their own
people David menen and others
nid sided with the you know proponents
of this risky work so even though there
was a moratorium in 2014 that Obama held
pass in 2017
fouchy and and Collins redefined the law
they said well it's not gain a function
research of concern if you're doing gain
a function research of concern to make
vaccines which is like saying it's not
nuclear weapons development if you
develop nuclear weapons to test bunkers
when obviously that would be very
unethical and morally repulsive to
anyone in the public who heard that
reasoning and that again
2017 in that time range Peter dasac
thanked ni for overturning his own
moratorium and pause on on his gain of
function funding pause on his work in
this niad grant that in 2020 he says he
found these China gen Bank sequences
that we should not publish and so you
have to trace it back you know there are
these systemic problems in science and
they relate to this inequality of power
that comes from science funders being
able to choose the winners of Science
and you know there that that's been a
very difficult thing to overturn and
Anthony fouchy being the head of niid
for 30 years has so many Connections in
the media and he has so many connections
at science the magazine to help science
journalists tell the story he wishes to
tell so when you see proximal origin
written and then days later Anthony
fouchy using his bully pulpit as a head
of niid talking to international news
outlets saying oh there's this paper I
don't know who wrote it you know I don't
know the authors but it shows
conclusively this did not come from a
lab without disclosing that again his
agency supported This research
overturned the moratorium and funded
these EXO collaborators in 2019
what we're seeing is this very systemic
problem it's you know we would like to
localize it you know I don't want to
localize it too much because this isn't
the fault of a grad student that took
over a vial or was bitten by a mouse you
know this goes higher than that yeah uh
yeah and that that idea of you know
either decentralizing science funding or
building some more firewalls between the
people in political power and the people
uh giving out the grants is something
we've talked about on the show before in
terms of other covid Po in terms of
basically covid policy that was
questioned uh throughout the pandemic
and I I think it's I hope it's something
that someone in Congress you know picks
up and and runs with um in terms of you
know what needs to be uncovered at this
point what what more information needs
to be Pride out of people's hands or
email inboxes by journalists or
Congressional investigators ERS you know
I'm really haunted by this theory that
Rand Paul laid out when I spoke to him
late last year he's someone who's uh
continued to press on this issue I want
to play a clip of what Senator Senator
Paul thinks is the best theory as to
where this all started based on the
intelligence that he's reviewed and then
get your reactions to that as we start
to bring this to a close let's roll that
Rand clip your best theory is is that
the Chinese created a virus covid in
order to try to create a vaccine to
oppose it to try to see if they could
create a vaccine that would work for all
Corona viruses the person who was uh
working on these vaccines we know his
name a general zo yusen and he's
developing this vaccine sometime in 2019
but he has to have somebody develop a
mutant Corona virus that actually
infects humans well we think that's what
Co was was developed in the lab to
create the vaccine we also know that zo
got a vaccine and he has it created by
February of 2020 and most people think
there's no way you could have gotten it
that quickly unless he'd been working on
it for some time we also know that this
General dies mysteriously two months
later so there's a lot to be said here
that what was going on is a creation of
a virus creating a gain of function
Corona virus that would infect humans
easily and then uh creating a vaccine
from that and what happened is that uh
it accidentally got out of the
lab okay so R what Rand Paul's
referencing is this General in China's
people's Liberation Army the pla zo
yusen um and according to the House
minority select committee on
intelligence report uh on the origins of
covid uh hold on I head it here oh yeah
they said that a s so that General zo
had reportedly worked with the wi with
the Wuhan Institute for orology for
years before the pandemic General Zoo
had worked extensively on coronav vir
research coronav virus research for
several years and on February 20th
February 24th 2020 a team led by General
Zoo filed a patent application for a
covid-19 vaccine which the authors here
characterize as in improbably fast
timeline notably in the spring of 2020
AS Global covid-19 cases surpassed 7
million and covid-19 deaths surpassed
400,000 General zo reportedly died under
mysterious circumstances you know that
and just to uh bracket that for a
second uh you know we don't we have
limited information about what goes on
in China we're relying on you know
reports from uh intelligence agents who
are getting reports from people on the
ground and they're you know they take
their analysis is that he may have
fallen off the roof of one of these Labs
um but anyway in light of the
information above they continue it's
plausible to hypothesize that General
zo's team of researchers already
possessed Co SARS CV 2 prior to the
pandemic as part of bioweapons research
and was working on vaccine related
experiments involving the virus in 2019
and that a safety incident at the
uh Institute led to its release into the
world so the hypothesis is that
basically they're trying to create like
almost a a universal covid or um Corona
virus vaccine and this was like the the
virus they created to test against that
um but you know do you have any
obviously none of us have any special
insight about what went on in China um
but what really concerned me about all
of it is the overlap between military
operations and science throughout this
whole story really whether it's the pla
in China or DARPA in the US um what have
you found pulling on those kinds of
threads
Emily so my recollection is that General
Zao um his death was not announced in
the way you would expect from a
scientist of his Prestige um whether or
not he was pushed out of a window of the
wi um I don't know I'd love to see that
intelligence um and whether or not that
abbreviated vaccine development timeline
is a red flag um I don't feel qualified
enough to um assess that I think there
are um conflicting opinions um and some
debate about that because I guess the
counterargument would be I believe madna
developed their vaccine extremely fast
maybe even as early as January so that
that's like the nature of mRNA
technology so that is a possibility
right right right um I do know through
our reporting we obtained last year uh
three state department cables um or two
excuse me two State Department cables
that um detail involvement of the pla at
the
wi um this is something that XI Jen Lee
was not honest about um so that's
unusual um but unfortunately those
cables were heavily redacted um you know
the odni did put out a very brief um
summary of intelligence related to the
Wi that confirmed U military involvement
with the research there including
research on Corona viruses um but didn't
include a lot of detail um about the
nature of that research so I think we
need more information and both Chambers
of Commerce or both chambers of um
Congress uh unanimously approved a bill
saying that we need to declassify
intelligence related to the Wi and so I
think we deserve to know um more
information about that but I don't I
just don't know yeah yeah I mean it it's
like anytime you get into National
Security there's these major
transparency issues um and as I was
going through the documents that you
posted um I took a little screen
recording of just this series of
redacted Pages um in the documents um
and maybe we can have hunt roll those
for a second while we continue to talk
this is just a continuous like stream of
redacted pages so at some point
classification it just becomes a brick
wall and you have to either rely on
whistleblowers or a really motivated
investigator within the government so so
you know as we close out I'd like to
hear from each of you what is the next
step you'd like to see here either in
terms of some specific piece of
information coming forward policy action
being taken or even just a cultural
change within journalism or science um
let's go to Alex first and then uh give
Emily the last
word I think you asked the big question
Zach um I don't have a little answer for
it
um science we scientists need to be able
to construct better systems to hold each
other account
we need
to yeah the the concepts of
decentralizing science funding are
useful for the ability to just remove
these kingpins from this from the field
but there's still going to be the
questions about the research ethics and
risk-taking in science and when Ron Fier
published this work in science um and
when people publish similar work in
Nature and Science and cell um there was
this incentive for scientists to take
greater risks and I think scientists
need to evaluate our own system of
publication and Merit allocation and
funding to really think carefully about
Pandora's Box we haven't because we
haven't opened Pandora's Box quite like
this before and so I think there's going
to be some ma major social and systemic
issues I think scientists really need to
speak up and be independent um so that
we can start to restore trust in our
community and also help our community
stay away from these you know extremely
risky experiments and really I mean
after the Holocaust or after you know
the World War II Germany had a very
serious National Reckoning and has
embedded into his culture teaching kids
about how they went wrong and I think
scientists need to be focused explicitly
on that on how we went wrong from Ron
fusier to Anthony fouchi and Francis
Collins to Peter daac and more um and
then I think from the journalist side of
things there's a lot of structural
issues facing journalism I just want to
say that it's amazing to see what Emily
has has been able to do in this and I
think this is inspiring to me that there
are this there is this vast network of
people out there with you know with
sharp minds and you know stubborn heads
that are you pushing for this
information I think the key pieces of
information we need to hear from are
those China gen Bank sequences da act
withheld I think we need to hear
Communications from David morrens and
other program officers and NIH and IID
Emily herself and the US right to know
team already has for the standing for
uncc's Ralph baric who is also part of
this collaboration we need to be able to
pry openen these books look at it and
personally I'm not in a very retributive
mindset but I just think for the purpose
of safeguarding the world in the future
we have to have a full account while
everyone is live today you know before
someone falls from a roof or something
like that we need to be able to have an
account where people tell us what they
did and why they did it so that we can
actually create this social system in
science to prevent that from ever
happening again
Emily I don't know that I am hoping for
any specific policy outcome um or change
in the Press I just honestly want there
to be Clarity and a national Reckoning
for everyone who lost loved ones to the
pandemic um or who lost businesses or
major milestones in their life um I I
honestly think this will probably be my
last investigation and kind of been
approaching it that way I don't have a
lot of hope that you know journalism
will tomorrow be like actually this is
very valuable reporting um and we should
reward it I think um I just want there
to
be Clarity and some closure for people
who are grieving that's really my my one
hope well that that's kind of surprising
and and disappointing what why is this
why are you thinking this is your last
investigation are you just like there's
you're you've hit a brick
wall I don't know that I will be
employable after
this at least in the media as it exists
now so um yeah so I I don't I guess
think a lot about like this is how I
want the press to change you know I I
just want there to be Clarity around
this kind of most um Monumental thing
that has happened um in modern times so
that's really my hope I can e Emily
sentiment that the challenge of speaking
truth to power is power and as a
scientist trying to speak this truth
it's also affected my career um and
alienated me from colleagues and so this
is the kind of social system that we
exist in from journalism to science and
that's something we need to re-evaluate
and
reconstruct yeah to totally agreed
because uh if you two are being
marginalized to that extent where uh
you're you know you're feeling like
you're not even employable Within These
institutions going forward there's
something seriously wrong here and uh
hopefully um there's you know some sort
of uh turnaround here or some some Hope
on the
horizon um and uh that information
continues to come out and and correct uh
what is clearly been in uh just a series
of coverups and uh uh hubris and uh
errors uh and I just want to thank both
of you for you know joining me today to
walk us through it um and uh hope that
you you are able to continue your work
in in some form Emily cup Alex wasburn
thanks for coming on the show today
thank you Zach
[Music]
thanks for listening to just asking
questions these conversations appear on
reason's YouTube channel and Facebook
page every Thursday and the just asking
questions podcast feed every Friday
subscribe wherever you get your podcasts
and please rate and review the show